The joe rogan experience.
You know there,
there's a company that makes a rubber ring.
Yeah,
yeah.
Literally that's what I was talking about.
Yes.
I tried to put that shit on my wife.
It's pit my face.
Here's what's weird.
My Sharon was going to buy me that four just because I kept telling her like I'm
worried about ripping this finger off.
Right.
Mainly because of my wedding ring is definitely too small.
So she was looking at some of those,
a silicone rings and we were literally looking at it on her iPad in my kitchen.
I open Instagram and started looking,
it's like sponsored ad buy that ring company.
Uh,
isn't that what's weird?
It's very weird.
We were just talking about that.
We're just talking about that the other day that we stuff you and Jamie and
whoever was on the podcast,
we were talking about like having a conversation and if you have like Alexa or
if you have like certain things that like listen to you while you're talking
like maybe even possibly Siri and then all of a sudden you'll go to Google and
what you were talking about like slick trick broadheads or some shit like that
will show up in your Google ads.
You're like,
what in the fuck?
Maybe Siri.
Siri's a total fricking,
she is a peeping Tom.
He's in to face little Ho.
She,
I don't think she's too faced.
I think Shay Siri,
she doesn't have a single face.
You're a two faced bitch.
Oh,
you're not connected.
Is that a bad thing though?
I know it's weird what I mean potentially you could view that as something like
I would probably want to buy that and now that it's here in an easier way for me
to do it,
that is kind of good.
I'm just going to Amy devil's advocate.
If you say,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna die out here.
At that time,
Siri can step in and say,
would you like me to call a helicopter?
But when you're looking at rubber rings for your wedding ring and then it shows
up on your lap top.
Yeah.
At that point,
Jesus sellout this.
Let's get to the bottom of this.
Well,
it most certainly exists with Google because of,
I've looked at like,
what did it cheers.
I've looked at some.
You're milking it over there.
I'm all right.
Sadly,
I smoked pot though.
You didn't.
Oh,
you did a little sh.
Don't tell any sponsors.
I might've made that last part up.
This.
The problem is like you'll be looking at something super obscure like a,
like a Casio watch sound like Casio.
That's Casio.
Yeah.
All right.
It has its good one.
I like this one.
It's like a protech totally doesn't an accomplice in it totally doesn't look
like it.
It is a Casio look.
Manuel [inaudible] that shit.
Right ash,
but the eye,
but then all of a sudden they'll show you whatever you search for,
whatever it was,
whether it's surf boards,
fucking Hilda Berg tents.
There'll be for sale and you'll see like amazon.com ads for like what?
Like I was looking at Zeiss by knows the other day I read about it.
Yes,
actually,
yeah,
but then I read a review on them and I actually googled them,
but then like everywhere I went,
if I went online,
I would see a little Google ad for Zeiss by knows.
I'm like,
this is kind of creepy,
but that's different.
I think if you Google search it,
you're on the grid.
You are.
If you're on someone else's device in your home kitchen,
it's not like I was looking at it on mine.
I was on Sharon's Ipad then,
oh,
she was ordering me a ring on her iPad and we were talking about it.
Then I opened my Instagram up and here's the silicone rings as a sponsored
recommendation within my Instagram feed.
Okay.
He's backing up.
You gotta back it up,
back it up.
Oh,
I want a drink of water.
Go back to that.
Gmail is free for a reason.
These are all free services we're using and not paying for,
so you have to give up a little bit to get these cool things to give up your,
I get it.
Your privilege.
Here's my position,
my whole,
everything I think of is out there.
I'm a professional talker.
Every,
every the most fucked up ideas I've ever had have all been recorded.